uh
time sure tough being a dc fan whilst
marvel are out here announcing their big
movies for the mcu we have warner
brothers constantly on us telling us
it's rain and then whilst we're drying
our clothes they're [ __ ] our mothers
behind our backs marvel will give you
x-men for christmas whilst dc will tell
you santa's not real and then kill your
duck
can't say that
now after a disappointing san diego
comic-con a little glimmer of hope shone
through when we discovered that ben
affleck was returning to shoot some
additional scenes for aquaman too after
months of pr disasters with ezra miller
it seemed like the merger may have
changed some things at the studio
however yesterday showed us that warner
bros always gonna warner bros and we now
know that batgirl has been cancelled
indefinitely the movie was set to take
place after the events of the flash and
it would see michael keaton return as
bruce wayne with him taking on a new
protege in barbara gordon leslie grace
appeared to be super enthusiastic over
the role and it seemed like young girls
would finally have a new icon that they
could look up to sorry though kids
you're stuck idolizing ezra miller as
the project is now shelved with the
company flushing 90 million dollars down
the drain could have used it to feed the
homeless but nope as we say warner bros
always good a water bros heard the movie
got cancelled by warner brothers and
worst thing is they didn't even warner
brother
this story was first broken by the new
york post who said that the film was
irredeemable and not exactly the best
news outlet and thus when the story
dropped it was quickly dismissed however
the rap followed up on it and when
variety weighed in we had enough variety
to know it was true now this is an
unprecedented move with the movie
actually almost being completely
finished however it's found itself to be
a victim of the discovery merger with a
company stating that they want big
blockbusters going forward
girl was created to show that hbo max
could have theatrical level of ends
debuting on it but discovery had gone
with the focus back to theaters and they
apparently don't think that it's good
enough to release in cinemas they wanted
to push back towards a theatrical
experience and never had the confidence
that batgirl could hit at that level
because of this we now live in a society
where morbius was released twice in
theaters but batgirl can't even get
dumped on hbo max
[Music]
now the rap features a paragraph
discussing the move and they said the
following the leaders of the studio
determined ultimately in spite of
reshoots and increased budget that the
movie simply did not work according to
insiders the new owners and management
led by ceo david zaslav are committed to
making dc titles big theatrical event
films and batgirl isn't that so so i'll
stop with jackson now insiders have
added that the studio brass loves the
film's directors and stars and are
actively planning to work with them soon
good luck with that i can't see them
coming back especially after they've
just wasted a massive amount of time now
this completely boggles my mind as it
was purposely shot to be dropped on the
streaming platform but this was like a
change so it would have a theatrical
release we're at this studio then
dropped their comments about it not
being a big event film and rather than
releasing it at all they've just went
with hiding it under the mattress like
in 90s loaded mags with jordan on the
cover
now like i said i can't see the stars of
directors wanting to work with the
studio again and i actually think it
might put off future filmmakers there
was a lot of controversy with
christopher nolan stepping away from
warner brothers when they started
releasing their films on hbo max and
this is way way way worse than that
films are extremely time consuming with
most of them taking at least two years
to plan film and release knowing all
that time could be wasted will likely
make directors and creatives cautious
which i think will backfire on warner
brothers in the long run if a property
like batgirl that stars michael keaton
as batman can get shelved then it shows
they're taking no prisoners and will
waste time and money if they don't see
the movie as being worth it now with it
being almost complete and hbo max being
an available avenue i just don't
understand why warner brothers have
decided that it shouldn't come out at
all i'm not sure what the logistics are
of just putting something on a streaming
service but with almost 100 million
being spent on it you think they'd at
least just put it on there which would
likely cost them very little now it's
also currently being reported that this
could end up being used as a tax write
down which basically means that warner
brothers will claim it as a loss in
doing this it also means they'll never
be able to release it in a monetizable
way because they've already claimed it
against tax purposes because of this you
can't really be like well this is a
write-off but we're gonna make money now
hence why it can't come out now this is
also being murdered in scoob holiday
horned which now can't come out either
producer and writer tony cavone came out
and said that the movie was practically
finished and that he's completely
heartbroken about it i think we're gonna
have to start some new hashtags i'm
surprised they aren't releasing batgirl
even as a multiverse movie the plan
before the discovery merger was to have
multiple timelines existing so that we
could get robert pattinson's batman
joaquin phoenix's joker and also the
main dark knight in the dc eu however
when the cutting movies like this off it
seems like that just won't be happening
i think it speaks to greater problems at
warner brothers that they're constantly
flip-flopping and changing their minds
although this is a new company that's
taken over ownership and they're wiping
the slide clean it still doesn't fill me
with confidence that they know what
they're doing this comes off the back of
them also canceling a wonder twins movie
and it seems like they might go back to
the old model where we only get films
from the big characters like your
batmans and supermans marvel have shown
that you can make minor ones a success
and i think discoveries seem to be
getting the divorce before they've even
gotten married
90 million dollars is a lot to throw
away and i was really excited to see
what they were going to do with the
movie especially with keaton coming back
as we've seen from zack snyder's justice
league that film was almost completed
but when zach left they ended up
reshooting 75 of it throwing more money
down the train they then released the
sign occurred after spending an extra 70
million when they probably could have
just salvaged what zac had created not
hired joss whedon to reshoot most of it
and then release that warner brothers
yeah they still don't seem like they
have a concrete plan in place and when
you compare them to marvel it becomes
abundantly clear how badly they've
mishandled things man of steel was
released in 2013 almost 10 years ago and
it still hasn't had a proper sequel on
the marvel side of things when they were
nine years deep we saw the release of
thor ragnarok completing his trilogy it
also done iron man's and caps trilogy
too and it's just a shining example of
mismanagement across the board now this
also doesn't fill me with a lot of
confidence that the blue beetle movie
will get released either that film has
now finished filming but if batgirl can
get canned then he can too there is a
lot of celebrating amongst the snyder
community that this shows that the
universe will be restored i think that's
the direction that warner brothers
should go in all honesty but i think
that both these kinds of films can
co-exist because of the multiverse
strategy that they were going with they
seem to be dead against that though and
i think we'll also see static shock get
dropped too they just seem to want to
focus on the big names and to have them
established before creating a bigger
universe there's a lot of talk that
cancelling batgirl proves warner
brothers is 100 committed to fixing dc's
image but i just can't see that
happening unfortunately i think dc is
always gonna have that where they're
viewed as being slightly lesser than
marvel if you look at some of their last
films like joker the batman
schneiderker suicide squad birds of prey
to me they're all really great films but
still dc have this image that they're
just not very good i class all those
movies as being better than marvel's
phase four but it's just so hard for dc
to shake that image at this point i
don't think canceling batgirl is really
gonna make a difference you also have a
big discovery event coming up on
thursday and expect to see this
basically be a massacre where a lot of
projects get taken out now whenever
stuff like this happens you're obviously
gonna have people looking at what else
they're committed to releasing and once
more ezra miller is trending on twitter
warner brothers pr is like this right
now and due to all the controversy
surrounding them there were calls to
scrap the flash however insiders
reported that the studio weren't willing
to lose 200 million dollars and that
they were still going ahead with it
however if he can lose 90 million on a
non-problematic production then i think
200 million on one with such controversy
surrounding it can't really be excused
in general the optics surrounding the
company look really bad we have ray
fisher who's now no longer part of the
flash because he spoke up about racism
in the company you also have a plc
actress that's had her entire movie
shelved and whilst all this is going on
ezra miller is treating hawaii like
grand theft auto we also have amber
heard coming fresh off the back of her
defamation lawsuit loss and as of now
his scenes are still an aquaman too
johnny depp was of course fired from
fantastic beasts and yet just a mess of
them consistently backing the wrong
horse it's led to appear on nightmare
and i really do think that we have to
question what's going on with the studio
according to variety they're still
deciding what to do with the film i
think their silence speaks volumes
ezra's like this right now watching
other movies get thrown into the trash
whilst the flash goes full steam ahead
now i know miller still has supporters
but i think the overall backlash to the
movie is gonna be so big that they're
gonna wanna rethink whether it's worth
putting out at all to me batgirl
deserved a chance at least and with it
being almost complete they could have
released it seen what the feedback was
and then have pivoted if it was negative
now whenever something like this happens
you're of course gonna have people who
see it as a good thing and i've seen
comments saying that this shows
discovery are taking things seriously if
they're willing to do this it shows they
have a certain standard that the movies
have to hit and overall it might be
better in the long run i think i stand
with the majority though when i say i'm
pretty shocked by this and out of all
the movies i was expecting to get canned
this definitely wasn't one of them if
flash does get shelved then we might
even see keaton completely step away
from being batman and who knows aflac
could come back fully that's the only
real silver lining i can find in this
but i still would have loved to have
seen keaton back now this comes days
after michael keaton stated that he
doesn't even watch marvel or dc movies
so if the flash does get shelved too and
he'll have been in two comic book movies
that got canned and he'll never even
know it because he doesn't watch them
anyway still though we'll always have
mobius and for now i want to put it to
you what do you think of the news are
you happy are you
i kind of hope that someone just posts
an mp4 of the whole movie and to me it
shows how antiquated the company is this
was created to push hbo max as the
feature seems to be in streaming but
discovery want to go back to the old
ways and try and say what many view is a
dying way to release movies it's all
going to be fun to talk about keep it
civil yeah don't be one of those guys
who's toxic in the comments no one likes
them and i'll tell you what if you're
nice yet you'll get entered into a
competition where we're giving away
three copies of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness on the 15th all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment it might not have to be nice
here i'll let you off there with your
thoughts on the news we picked the
comments on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that you message me on twitter heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out
upright on the westworld season six
definitely not getting any screeners for
any hbo max shows anytime soon so that's
probably the last one i'm going to have
out early so head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video i'll be poor i'll see
you next time take care peace